so bring in Ben Roethlisberger these
Steelers quarterback how's morale been
we're doing well after a big win and
that makes you feel good
how much football did you watch on
Monday night with the Patriots in the
Dolphins typically Monday Night Football
I watch about 1/2 then I go to bed but
my two oldest were both sick so I was
busy cleaning up throw-up bucket i watch
most of it what would you take away when
you watch a game what are you watching
as opposed to what the normal casual fan
is I watched the ball but I watched the
quarterbacks I watched when New England
was on defense I kind of watched them to
see blitzes and looks things like that
just just any little tidbit but like I
said most of my attention was on what
the kids what do you see when you see
that Patriots defense I see a group
that's very good in the secondary that's
opportunistic that makes plays I see a
group that upfront just doesn't want to
do anything special they just want to
contain you get a little pressure on you
and make you throw it whether a little
bit early you know when you're not quite
ready maybe only rushed three guys and
drop eight and make it difficult for you
to find a holes throw could you build me
the perfect quarterback probably with
some time but let's say we were doing
footwork arm strength and if you want to
do it all time instead of just going
over today's quarterback but I'm just
curious if if you were taking attributes
with all these quarterbacks what would
you factor in well I mean you've got to
have you know a big arm a quick release
guy you know he's always say that Elway
could throw it through a car washing the
ball wouldn't get wet okay you know I
mean I'm going all the time you can do
proper Aaron Rodgers in that category
but and you know you wanna have a guy
that's got good footwork not necessarily
a runner I'm not talking a guy like you
know Cam Newton someone that can run and
run
people over and run away from people
just some of those guys good footwork in
the pocket can slide one needs to step
up one needs to you know you talk about
a drew brees I think and I think you can
come sit on you create Tom Brady what do
you do better than Brady I don't know
maybe I don't know maybe shrug I like to
get all Dolph defenders off me
that is true he's smart he's smart he's
smart he goes down and I don't very
smart I don't go down have you ever
taken a hit where you go that what I was
stupid why didn't I just go but that is
that's what you're known for so you
can't all of a sudden like go down and
take a knee can you I mean that's part
of it so your game yeah that's not me
I'm not you know we've seen quarterbacks
in the past kind of the old Phantom sack
go down as guys are getting close I
can't do it it's just the competitor in
me says fight for every every inch you
can get what is it like in the huddle
when guys come back and of course
everybody's open but but how do you
maintain sort of the decorum of the
huddle and you're the leader there when
everybody's probably chirping saying or
do you want to hear that they're open I
don't know what a quarterback wants to
hear if anything when he gets in the
huddle usually not in the huddle I mean
if I don't want to hear it from them
first I may ask hey what do you have on
that or it goes a run play you know how
was he playing with you head up with the
inside for me I want to get on the
sideline I want to I want to look at the
pictures because then I have visual
evidence of when they're not really open
but they say they were um so it's you
know it's really about just
communicating and talking and and when
you come in the huddle it's you know I
know what play they're I'm calling or is
being called and I know kind of who the
primary is so I try to let that guy know
like hey you know I need you to run your
best route here or line I need a little
bit more time here or whatever it is so
just try and give guys a little bit of
encouragement how many different signals
would you have with Antonio Brown when
you get to the line of scrimmage if you
change something do you have specific
things looks words signals for him yes
we have a lot of but it's not just for
him
you know it's our home no-huddle package
we have hand signals for almost all of
it you know there's some little things
that maybe Amy and I have that no one
else does but that might be just two or
three things I I i want everybody all
our receivers to be able to to run
everything and know all the signals and
all the code words and all that stuff in
case there's a moment that we need it
you know whether it's a bee is not in
there or we have it to someone else do
you ever have fun with your audibles
yes couple weeks ago our dilly dilly oh
yeah but I know is that an inside joke
that you know is somebody laughing at
the the Budweiser reference there I I
think so yeah I mean it happened earlier
in that week say ow
Villanueva came in and he had just he
had a big beard like the week before he
shaved it all off and he just had a
moustache a big moustache and so he came
in and he was being all silly like you
know going off the commercial like Billy
Billy and he just looked the part you
know he's real big and had this big
mustache so we were all laughing about
it and it walked through him like hey
guys if I give you a dilly dilly call
this is what a game is just I'll just
laughed it just it was a walk through
like we didn't even think about it then
in a game I don't know why it just came
to my mind so I did it and we you know
luckily it worked and it was funny but
why do you do Omaha no we don't do I
don't know him huh but how did why was
Omaha so prevalent there first I know
Payton did it but like is there did you
have oh oh I don't think Omaha is
anything different than like hurry
you know just it's just a one word that
you know the ball was being snapped
right after it or on a particular week
it wasn't being snapped right after to
get guys to jump I think Payton just did
it it felt like every single play so I
think it just you heard it waaaay more
do you ever have that guy who knows
exactly what you're calling when he
autumn when you audible he audibles on
the defensive side you go I'll be damned
he got me sometimes I would say all not
all the time not very often but every
once while you'll call something and
they'll be like they may not know the
exact play but they might know okay
drawl or run to the right or run left or
something like that every once in a
while but I
I find it more funny when they they call
like watch the screen in your life
taking a deep shot or something you know
or watch the run in your passive oval to
make me laugh
should a wide receiver in this case
Antonio Brown be a top candidate for MVP
did you make a case really yeah
absolutely he's the best of business you
know he's not just a deep ball guy he's
not just a guy that is only on third
downs he's catch the ball all downs all
situations and you look at the
prototypical size of a wide receiver
that's not him so he's he's under sized
he's probably out the fastest the
quickest but when he gets the ball in
his hand or to get open he's something
special so I absolutely he should be a
candidate we had Will Ferrell on Canada
we had Will Ferrell on recently and he
says that you know occasionally people
will say that he looks like you do you
get the other way around
yes all the time people think you will
Ferrell yes we do the rookie show you
know at the training camp every year
they do like look-alikes yeah you know
like coach Tomlin gets the who's it apps
to actor apps more absolutely more apps
yeah we so we get all kinds of that
stuff and it never fails every year they
put Will Ferrell and myself up have you
met him every year I have I actually I
don't know if he'll remember this story
but is he after my rookie year or my
second year coming after the ESPYs we
were walking out to get in the car and
he was there and I was like oh my
goodness I mean Wolfer walked up and
said hello and he was like hey has
anybody ever told you that we look like
yes I get all the time because we are
two good-looking guys are we major day
yes I did
all right final serious question you
versus Brady 40-yard dash oh I I mean
I'd have to beat him I think I'm younger
that's the only reason he's got a knee
brace on I I would hope so it'd be kind
of funny maybe we should do that
sometime just for fun if Russell Wilson
ran backwards and you guys ran forward
oh no that's Barry he's not gonna beat
us backwards that's embarrassing we're
athletes good for you why would take
Russell but I look I
I appreciate your confidence you you're
gonna need that you're gonna need that
have fun this weekend good to catch up
with you Ben thanks for joining us you
too that's Ben Roethlisberger Steelers
quarterback for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]